the jogan experience it's been so
interesting my my journey I feel like I
always try to look for people
to compare and see how they did things
and maybe take the positives and
negatives and and apply those to what
I'm doing and there really hasn't been
that many people that have done what
what I've done I'm 5 and0 right now I
started training in August of 2021 MMA
it's hilarious yeah I know I started so
I started that really is so fun
that is so [__] crazy yeah yeah I
know it's well Dan White originally was
like like wait a while yeah like I don't
want you get to in the UFC that so that
it'll get bring me around to to the
point you made so what happened was I I
started training um four weeks later I
was like yo like let's I'm fre let's get
a fight like so I took an amateur fight
and uh just some poor dude like didn't
know what he was doing he was 0 and or
One and0 amateur I was 0 and0 and and he
took the fight and I think a lot of
people there was a lot of question marks
people were like all right I don't know
like let's see let's see what's up and I
choked the guy out and I was like let's
go again four weeks later I fought my
second amateur fight knocked the dude
out cold and then I then I was like all
right well I wanted to uh put a show
together in my hometown in State College
and uh so I was working for a few months
to get that going and it just there was
the PA athletic commission is working
between my management team the PA
athletic commission and Penn State there
was just too many movement Parts it was
tough and I was like I need a fight so
you know I could wait like four more
months and do this or I could just get a
fight so then um I had trained another
six months six seven months and I was
like let's do it pro debut and that was
in June of
2022 and uh so I'm coming out against a
you know another poor guy who thought
like he was going to knock me out or
something and uh knock him out in 30
seconds on UFC Fight Pass and it did
like the most views in UFC Fight Pass
history um like more than any other
promotion it was like something like
three or 4 million views in the week and
so then and uh it did a bunch that night
here it is yeah this is
it so this is eight months of
training it's just that's what's crazy
is that you're you're such a good
Striker so quick yeah it's really nuts
man it really is very very unusual but I
just think it's got to be the same
mindset that allowed you to get a lead
at wrestling you just programed that
into striking yeah that's exactly
exactly what it is on top of good high
quality coaches and training Partners
like that's everything and uh so so
after this happened the next morning UFC
Bellator 1fc pfl boom boom boom call
let's do it let's do it do and I'm like
what the freak like I'm one and0 pro
haven't even trained like I've been
training eight months or whatever nine
months so was there hesitancy on your
part where you like I look I'd like to
get some more fights more competition
because we've seen it before like P is a
great example he's got a couple fights
at the UFC and then all of a sudden he's
fighting for the title yeah yeah so my
initial plan like before any of this
happened was I'm GNA get 10 fights and
the regional scene you know and then I'm
going to go to UFC I'm be the champ by
like 13 14 fights like that's what
that's where the plan was and uh then
after that it was like everybody kind of
knows what's up everybody's trying to
sign me and um I talked with my manager
and I was like dude am I even going to
be able to get a fight like who's going
to fight me on these Regional scene
promotion like who's going to fight me
and any of these he's like I'll be
honest with you like nobody's going to
fight you and I'm like okay well then
you know my mind I was always I'm going
to the UFC like you know these other
organizations I I think they they do a
good job and stuff but that that that's
not really me like I'm I'm a UFC guy so
you know discuss with the UFC and
they're like hey well you know we can
throw you on contenders and and uh I'm
like let's do it and it was a couple
months later
so I uh now I'm like it's on like let's
get it rolling I'm gonna fight these
contenders fights uh I fight my first
fight um choke the guy out in a minute
Dan's like let's do another fight I'm
like perfect let's do it like that's
great um so then I I fight at the uh the
last week of contender series and it's
actually a crazy story
so this is going to make me seem like a
real dummy but um my gym is like 200
yards away from where I live and uh
there's a a main road that you have to
cross to get to it it's probably like a
40 45 mph speed limit but it's not it's
not super busy but it's a little busy
and so I used to you know what a one
wheeel is so I used to ride my one
wheeel like two and from practice and uh
I would just do this all the time and so
I'm riding back from training session
once and uh I've got so I'm Barefoot
I've got like a Yeti bottle I've got my
phone and wallet and like my flipflop in
my hand and I've got no shirt on and I'm
just like it it takes like 25 seconds so
I'm just like and uh I'm go I'm going on
this road and my my buddy pulls behind
me he's leaving practice too and then I
have another car behind me and I'm like
oh freck like I better pick I don't want
to make these people wait I better pick
it up and normally I'm pretty safe on
this thing like I don't really go crazy
but I so you lean forward to go faster
so I'm leaning forward and I catch the
nose on the tip of the nose on the
asphalt and I slam into the ground and
roll and uh my Yeti I have like a 64 o
Yeti it's flying in the air my shoes
wall everything's flying in the air and
I hit and rolled and I just was like get
off the road you're going to get hit by
a car so I popped up grabbed my stuff
and got off the road and my buddy's
sitting there in his car and he's
like and I was like oh I just jumped in
the car with
him and I'm like take me home bro and he
just pulls into my driveway and uh he's
like you all right and I'm like ah yeah
I'm good like my shoulder hurts a little
bit but I'm good and I checked on my app
I was going 23 M hour oh Jesus so I was
flying and uh then you know I was like
I'll be fine like I kind of hurt my
shoulder hurts a little bit and then
four hours later I like couldn't move my
arm I was like I could get up to like
here and that was it and so then I go
get X-ray MRI and I cracked my collar
bone and I had like a separation in my
uh SC joint oh Jesus and uh I was like
this was 10 days before I was supposed
to fight my second contenders fight and
I was like
dude what am I going to do like this is
terrible and so I go to the athletic
trainer at Penn State he's like a
magician he's amazing he's worked with
the wrestling team for 30 years and he
does a lot of like kind of he's more
like Eastern philosophy guy so we're
moving energy through it and doing a few
different things and um I started to
feel a little better feel a little
better and I'm about to fly out to to
Vegas like the next day and I'm like
well it's it's the day before I'm about
to the two days before I'm about to fly
out I'm like okay if I wake up tomorrow
and I don't feel significantly better
like I'm going to have to pull out this
fight and so I woke up the next day and
I was like all right it feels okay it
feels it felt better so I hit pads and
like did a couple things and uh I was
like all right whatever let's just do it
so let's freaking go into the fight and
uh uh I ended up I knock that dude down
hit him in a triangle choke him out win
the fight in whatever less than a minute
and I'm like fired up and I'm like let's
go let's do it again get me in there
again December I tell tell Dana and
Hunter and they're like done and uh so
then everybody like he's fight in
December and I got back home and I was
like maybe we hold off a little bit so
uh then we we pushed my next fight till
March but I don't ride the one moral of
the story I don't ride the one wheel
anymore yeah [__] those things yeah
Jamie broke his ass bone on one of them
hoverboards H board yeah oh yeah simar
so I don't I don't do that anymore
but